yeah so you shared with us four
different propositions concerning
reconciliation among them between faith
and I kept thinking each time you said
the word face that I could potentially
substitute any other sort of identity
marker instead so for instance you were
talking about exclusivist faiths but I
can also think about political groups or
cultural groups or linguistic groups
that are also incredibly exclusivist
because of that exclusivism they have a
really hard time coming together and
producing improvements for the world so
the question is is there anything
distinct about the process of religious
reconciliation as opposed to
reconciliation between other types of
groups that are also competing whether
there are political or cultural or any
other sort of identity based on any
other sort of identity um what do you
think but I mean I think first of all in
a sense for me it's enough that
religious faith is such a you know it is
is such a an identity marker because
that if it's important than once you
deal with it I think there is an
intensity about religious belief that
distinguishes it doesn't always
distinguish it I mean some people can be
tense about their football card you know
now crazy people get about sport in this
country my country you know this team
might the team I support people actually
I remember guy going on TV and and
saying my football team is more
important to me than why I'm wife all my
children I mean
what this is ridiculous but so I agree
there are there are other think but I
think there is a there is more often and
intensity about religious faith and I
also think and a lot of those other
identity markers kind of come and go but
this is with us you know religious
conviction is not diminishing actually
it's one of the things we discovered
early on the course so I think it's
still very very important but I mean
you're right you could translate some of
that LOL so what do you know she knows
it strikes me as sometimes the sentiment
that the Trump's faith if i look at
american sensibilities often it from the
outside i may not understand America
really well but it seems to me often
that America is a most important
religion too many people of the
religious right and so forth
notwithstanding all the protestations it
really America does the real work of
loyalist going to write it is the point
of angelic makes Zach and since matter
to desire I mean since you can say there
are other issues that also divide people
but yeah but doesn't doesn't make
religion a real is religious very
different in some would we say would we
I mean is it qualitatively different in
some way well I think some of the things
that you have mentioned mentioned make
it different in service of attachment I
think also that it's a maybe it's it has
analogues other like ideologies often
say Marxism is an ideology served almost
like religion and define the self we
define the social relations it will
define the good it provide the whole
universe in which a person moved unlike
say soccer club right this is
overarching thing in which you you use
situate yourself and all the other
relations and if you if you connect that
with also powerful emotional attachments
it's really a powerful thing